the decision to end the sci-fi cult
favorite after two seasons has already
been made but why exactly did Netflix
execs decide to pull the plug on their
mind-bending mystery thriller here are a
few reasons why we think the oay was
cancelled Netflix doesn't release its
viewing figures so it's impossible to
say whether the amount of people
streaming the oay
impacted the decision to accent what we
do know is that the streamer makes these
decisions based on a simple ratio
viewership versus cost Netflix has
confirmed that it adheres to this
formula and according to The Wrap an
Insider with the knowledge of Netflix's
decision to cancel the drama two seasons
in has confirmed that the oay fell on
the wrong side of the equation the oay
was a big creative swing for the company
the source set and while it was one that
Netflix was proud to take it just wasn't
paying off in June 2019 Netflix chief
content officer Ted Saran dose
reportedly ordered dozens of his TV and
movie execs to rein in their spending
people familiar with the high level
meeting told the information it was made
clear that bigger budget projects needed
to bring in the viewers going forward
building buzz and Industry credibility
was no longer enough the Netflix
business model relies not only on the
retention of subscribers but the steady
influx of new ones and shows like the Oh
a don't help in that department
it was critically acclaimed yes but the
Netflix metric deem that it was no
longer a draw as a report by the
information put it Netflix has learned
that the first two seasons of a show are
key to bringing in subscribers but the
third in later seasons don't do much to
retain or win new subscribers and being
a show after the second season saves
money because show runners who oversee
production tend to negotiate a boost and
pay after two years understandably this
approach isn't popular with producers
especially those running shows designed
to be told over multiple seasons like
the oa1 creator of a Netflix show that
was axed after two seasons alleged it's
really hard to get Netflix to put money
into a third season for a creator you
want to be able to reward your audience
with more seasons she's gotta have it
American vandal and friends from college
all cancelled in 2019 also only got two
seasons Netflix has denied that this is
a new policy on the surface the oay is
your typical binge Worthy Netflix show
teasing viewers with glimpses of what's
to come in order to keep them rooted in
their seats for hours on
and that relationship between show and
viewer only functions if the build-up to
those glimpses is satisfying enough in
its own right however and in the case of
the Oh a that was very much a one-sided
relationship simply put the Oh a
required viewers to sit through hours of
speculative twists and turns for
ultimately buried little payoff in
return questions were answered with
questions that led to yet more questions
while traditional TV networks may be
willing to churn out
endless episodes of a show based on
mystery alone much like ABC's lost
Netflix isn't going to continue to fund
a show that loses people's interest
before they get to the payoff the oay
isn't for everybody
it's wildly imaginative and incredibly
well-executed but its mysteries are
often a bit too impenetrable part 1
ended with a school shooting dwara sake
of clarity what we'll call interpretive
dance one character swallows a sea
anenome during a near-death experience
in the same episode in which another
character swallows a bird given to her
by an angel with Braille on her face the
Oh a part two is equally weird and for
some critics it just went too far
according to indie wires Ben Travers
part 2 doubles down in a longer more
pretentious and less vigorous follow-up
season that's part puzzlebox part
romance and wholly insane if there's one
single moment in season 2 of the Oh a
that seemed to push people over the edge
it's when Britt Marlins original angel
meets a telepathic octopus yes a
telepathic octopus we had already been
through a whole lot of craziness by the
time the show's protagonists encounters
this creature whose name by the way is
old night I hold hope for your species
but he holds hope for our species this
extraordinary octopus communicates with
revelers at a packed nightclub via our
dimension traversing hero
and it was simply too much for some
viewers even ardent fans of the show
were left uh turley perplexed by what
they had witnessed and in true Oh a
fashion answers weren't exactly
forthcoming is this I just - lights bro
one of the biggest issues with the oay
is that it seemed to be catering almost
exclusively to a cult audience the show
built up a dedicated following after its
first season and rather than trying to
expand that following by making season 2
a little more accessible to new viewers
the oay seem to lean even further into
the weirdness the result was the second
season that isolated anyone that didn't
have the patience for telepathic
octopuses and dancing robots and
isolating potential customers isn't part
of the Netflix business model good the
fact that the oay pandered to expand I'm
a little too much have been a factor in
Netflix pulling the plug
according to slash films Joshua Meyer
the show seemed to take pleasure in the
fact that it created an exclusive club
for people who were willing to go along
with whatever it threw at them
Meyer wrote in his review of the O a
part 2 it gathers fans around itself in
a candlelit attic and seeks to regale
them with the tall tale the show has big
ideas but its characters are all too
quick to chase magic mirrors on blind
faith if you're invested in those
characters then you might be willing to
drink from the same pitcher of kool-aid
that they do could co-creators of the O
a Brit Marling and saw Batman Cleese
already be working on another project
for Netflix their first show might be
done but the language that marlene used
when she took to instagram following
news of the OAS cancellation seemed to
suggest that something else could be in
the pipeline the actress and producer
posted we feel profound gratitude to
Netflix and the people we have worked
with therefore making it possible to
make part 1 in part 2 while we cannot
finish this story I can promise you we
will tell others those other stories
could well be told via a different
platform but Netflix's statements on the
matter also suggested that their
relationship with marlene and batman
Gleaves wasn't over cindy Holland vice
president of original content for
Netflix said in a statement we are
incredibly proud of the 16 mesmerizing
chapters of the O a and are grateful to
Britain's all for sharing their
audacious vision we look forward to
working with them again in the future
and this and perhaps many other
dimensions there's no denying that
marlene is a huge talent with more to
offer and the dark layer that Batman
Glee's Broadus director of the Oh a
didn't go unnoticed here's hoping this
darling duo works together again soon
and gets to see their wild visions play
out in full check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a sing
one
[Music]